[Music]
today's question comes from nathan in
mississippi nathan writes how can i stop
worshiping money i'm currently on baby
step 3b and throughout these years of
grinding away to build my savings i
found myself so focused on the goal that
it's becoming all-consuming i work as a
truck driver and i work anywhere from 13
to 15 hours a night i'm tired and i'm
burnt out recently i feel god is telling
me to slow down and go at his pace
how can i still attack this thing
without feeling like i'm putting the
money before everything else
whenever i think of the word worship
dave um
i think of fear
think of
in awe of
and
like we just talked with the last caller
here i i spent years worshiping money
because it was something i was scared of
whether it was the scarcity i didn't
know how it worked i didn't know how
these stock markets were going up and
down and my neighbors houses were worth
whatever and so it took over and when i
got some insight about it and some
knowledge about it some people around me
that could coach me through it it lost
its power because i got some i had a
relationship
i learned more about it i wasn't scared
of it anymore
and i think about worshiping god and i
think there's an awe and a reverence and
a
uh
i would say like a destructive fear but
a healthy
relational fear there um what do you
think about that i think that's accurate
um the
the the thing is um
you you step to the side of any item
that becomes an idol
and you set it in its proper place in
your
mind and in your spiritual walk in your
life
and you say okay this is an item
it is a tool
money is really of no value except for
what it can do
it it makes a lousy god
it makes a lousy master
and also um makes a a lousy slave even
so uh you know you you you want to
control the money not it control you
and there's a difference you know the
only larry burkett used to say the only
difference in saving and hoarding is
your attitude
it's not an amount it's not a process
it's not a level of intentionality it's
not a level of diligence both are very
diligent savers investors and hoarders
they're very it's just your attitude
about it it's what are you trying to get
from it
not what are you doing right and not the
amount and not how many years you've
been doing or something like that so i'm
very intentional with money i actually
always have been even before i went
broke i've always been intentional
uh but but i i am a manager of it
since i went broke before that i was
more of a worshiper of it i thought it
was going to bring me happiness i
thought
if you think it's going to be your
provider yes then you've got it you've
given it too much power
and then you can set to the side but you
know the fact that you've been working
hard and hitting some goals and you want
to slow down
that's not a worshipping issue that's
just a realization that i'm at baby step
3b which is where we tell people to move
from intensity to intentionality like
the last caller yeah and you have to do
that you have to change your identity
right your identity was one of running
and crushing and getting this thing done
and now you're moving to one of
intentionality right place right time
now what are we going to do moving
forward right going for a live stream
i'm not a sprinter i'm a marathoner
there you go i changed my name yeah and
uh i used to be a sprinter because i had
to do that i had to run the cheetah was
chasing me so i had to run and and now i
can just calm down and and i don't have
to work seven days a week 15 hours a
night you know and uh god is telling you
to slow down
i think that probably was god
and uh but it's it but worshiping money
you can do when you don't have any when
you have a lot when you're in the middle
of it uh when you've got the other side
of it you can worship at any time that's
a position of the heart it's not a
position of the money uh or a baby step
or anything like that
um
and you know that does say so here's the
thing again i think it's a good both of
these are questions are somewhat
parallel uh and so
it's really important for you folks out
there to hear
i am all about we at ramsey are all
about
you going absolutely crazy and i don't
care how hard you work i don't care if
you're working 40 hours a day
for a short period of time to get your
freaking mess cleaned up you spent four
years five years nine years making a
mess you are not going to clean that up
in nine days
you are going to have to roll up your
sleeves and sacrifice and hurt
there's going to be pain involved
discomfort
inconvenience i'm not going to see my
baby your baby's asleep while you're
working you need to get your butt in
gear and clean up your mess for the sake
of your family that type of stuff is
gazelle intensity we call it is for baby
steps one through three and is generally
somewhere in the 18 to 24 month range i
don't i don't ask people to do that for
five years it's very unusual sometimes
you have to but it's very unusual most
of the time it's one month to 24 months
and you are done
once you get out of debt everything but
your house and you have your emergency
fund in place we suggest
at ramsey that you take your foot off
the gas back it off a little bit
go into marathon mode
and now you've got a more balanced
schedule you drop some of those side
hustles and now you're going to spend
more time with your family which by the
way is going to be a better quality of
time because you don't have this debt
hanging over you and you're not
preoccupied with mastercard calling your
phone while you're trying to play with
your kids
and i also think it's important that for
the last caller too
there are seasons of every single job
when these are 60 or 70 hour a week
months right and that's just part of
life and i think the challenge that most
have is they don't know how to have that
conversation at home with their spouse
with their kids
um and i'm thinking back to before the
before we went through this book season
like sheila and i sat down with the
calendar and said here's what this is
gonna look like now and she's all in got
it and then here's what it's going to
look like when my foot comes off the gas
right and we can reconnect and then this
so i think it's about being intentional
about like you mentioned it it's about
the intentional but you can't be scared
of hard work man in the name of
if i miss this in the name of nurture if
i miss this one game then i'm the
terrible dad and yeah the worst and all
that kind of stuff
but don't set your life up where you
miss them all right absolutely yes
because you're so freaking broke you
can't breathe that's right you know so
get the mess straightened up and
sometimes it's just to hit a goal yeah
sometimes it's just to do some stuff
like uh tomorrow
uh
i for the next three days sharon and i
have rachel's kids
and we won't be doing anything
except rachel's kids for three days uh
the next thursday
i will leave here early in the morning
and end up in orlando and i will have
lunches and dinners and events and
building wealth and then we have entree
leadership summit that begins on sunday
i'm speaking at a church on sunday
morning and uh for the next seven days
after that i'm probably going to do
80 hours
and i don't even have to work
but i'm doing that to hit some goals but
there's a ebb and flow to this
that you know and that's scheduled i'm
emotionally prepared and it's not
forever it's for seven whole days he's
not going to kill old dave you know he's
not going to whine about it you know but
i'm going to hit some serious goals
during that time and our team is going
to hit some serious goals during that
time and i'm leading the charge the
front of the horse with the sword
pointed forward you know and uh hey game
on but i'm not doing 80 hours a week
anymore
seven days a week for
you know months on end and you just did
it
week for this right i did a long time
ago for this right and my kids all
survived it barely
this is the ramsey chef